you was the casting director guy named
ulysses from new york city and i was
like i'm going to do a nigerian accent
they were like what i said yeah
everybody's doing the ghetto yo [ __ ]
that i said let snoop dogg be the ghetto
dude and i'll be the nigerian guy and we
can clash and bump head oh yeah yeah
yeah and i got the part in the room wow
and i all everything i did in seoul
plane is all improv wow i need you give
me the nigerian give me a nigerian
accent for what i can do it it's very
easy
bobby you are very funny i don't
understand why you're not doing your
hour
i cannot yeah that's my father's it's my
father's act can i can i try yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay
no no wait wait listen let me learn let
you learn cause you're on a road for
fruitfulness i'm fruiting
okay here we go we'll give you a simple
one word for all right ready how are you
how are you oh
hey
okay ready what is your name
what is your name hey you almost sounded
a little like
what is your
what is your name what is your name what
is your name that's it what is your name
what is your name
you got a little it goes you got a
little asia what yeah yeah
yeah
use your common sense ah
use your common sense
almost like native americans
give me one more shot and then you get a
shot you don't need a shot but i can
promise i'm better than you try it
you're ready
use your common sense
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what nigerians don't have lists no
yeah there's gotta be one guy with a
list no someone said we're a youth
where's what's what are you doing here
all right
i have a speech impediment all right so
i'm gonna
let's pass on that right let's try it i
wanna try a different completely
different accent okay let's uh you
should also should also test korean oh
yeah do you mind
yeah yeah
i guess dude
with the bulgogi
wow oma
he knows everything listen oma hajima
you know how i know omaha
my friend hank korean stop mom you're
right stop yeah yeah yeah he was getting
his ass whooped korean parents will [ __ ]
you up
this is chicago yeah my little league i
was playing little league i'm like 10 9
10.
his mom is [ __ ] smacking him he's
going uma hajima hajima and we're like
yo hank
what's the hachima [ __ ] man yeah yeah he
was like i'm saying mom stop stop
yeah yeah so i got that korean no but
give me another accent okay um oh uh oh
uh what about um
um [ __ ]
like a cuban dominican or whatever try
okay i don't like that
i don't like that
i don't like that i don't like that i
don't like that i don't like the way
you're coming i don't like that one i
don't like the way you're coming at me
no a lot a lot of times you know my like
my wife she's always talking to me
[Laughter]
um disproportionately large tongue for
how small his mouth is thank you all
right there we go thank you it's like
real thick and meaty thick and me
can you look at what a really large
tongue might mean i i do
yeah look at that meat no yours is like
but
yeah
mouth is so small and your tongue is so
like okay yeah don't you okay that means
you should be able to do donald trump
okay you can do donald trump yeah go
ahead you people are great who cares
bobby lee you're amazing i can't do it
bobby lee deserves you deserve an hour
the writers were just like
we don't know and then the producer
would just give him the tapes
like send me like what tapes like irish
accent tapes oh really right and spent a
whole weekend listening to it and then i
would go to the table read and then just
be like nah just enough you just don't
do
i just can't really do anything really
in that way
yeah so my point is is that
because but here's the thing all right
what i've always known about wait do you
know filipino accent yeah they always
say uh capri you're getting bigger every
time i see you
every time i see you you're getting
bigger very funny funny
yeah bunny funny
f my my see i lived in a building in in
chicago it's called uptown it's the most
integrated area because chicago's the
most segregated city in the country so i
lived well it was all immigrants so it's
like i my next door neighbors were from
cambodia then downer down hall was um
um is it castillos that their filipino
and then there was african-american then
there was a